how do you put your eye back in let me
show you so there's two dots at the top
of the eye
and they're there to help me so i know
which part of the eye is the top
that way i don't put my eye in sideways
so what holds in a prosthetic eye is
actually just your eyelids
so in order to put your eye in the only
thing you pretty much have to do is just
dig
under your eyelid so i always start with
the top eyelid
i just kind of pull it up and kind of
push my eye
up under it and then i pull my bottom
eyelid down
and my eye kind of just sits right in
there and that's how you put in a
prosthetic eye
can you show us how you clean your eye
yes so the first step
is to take the eye out
the second step is to plug the sink so i
do not lose my eyeball that would not be
good
the third step is to fill the sink with
warm water
the next step is to put my eye in the
water and let it rinse off
i then grab my eye put a squirt of soap
on it
and wash it off i now
rinse the soap off with warm water
because if i got soap in my eye socket
that would sting and the last step
before putting it back
in is to dry it off and just like that
we have a clean eyeball
story time on how you lost your eye
please i've answered this before however
i've had a lot of new followers ask me
how i've lost it
so let's get right into it when i was
two years old my mom had taken a picture
of our family right after my sister was
born
and in that picture she noticed that i
had a gold film around my eye
she was kind of curious and concerned
about that so she showed it to the
doctor when my sister's two week checkup
came around
and he was also kind of curious and
concerned so they sent me to a different
hospital to do tests and x-rays to see
if i had anything
and when the test results came back they
found out that i had a rare type of
cancer in the retina of my eye
called retinoblastoma so the doctors
gave my parents two options
one to remove my eye and take out all
the cancer with it or two
go through chemotherapy which would
allow me to keep my eye however there
would be a chance of the cancer
spreading and possibly me dying
so without a doubt my parents chose to
remove my eye so that their child
wouldn't die
and i'm so thankful for my parents
making that decision as i've accepted
this as who i am
do you have any customized fake eyes let
me show you all the eyes that i have
i have three clear eyes which were used
after my eye surgery to heal my
eye socket before getting my prosthetic
eyes
and these are my four prosthetic eyes
they're all hand painted and custom
fitted to my eye socket
as you can see the eye on the right is
smaller than the rest as that was my
first eye when i was two years old
and then they gradually get bigger as i
have grown throughout the years
can you wear an eye patch um i don't
have one but let's go to walmart and see
if they have any
[Music]
let's go find an eye patch yeah do you
know where the eye patches are
you have to point it out yeah i'm
missing my eye
it's fake i don't want anything
so the girl wouldn't show me where the
eye patches were because looking at this
grossed her out apparently
so i had to find the eye patches by
myself but i found them
so let's put this bad boy on
[Music]
and just like that we have ourselves an
eye patch
does it hurt to touch the skin behind
your eye how can anyone do that
well i'm about to show you first take
out your eye
and second touch the skin behind your
eye yeah that does hurt it's like a
really bad burning sensation honestly